تواصل سلطات الاحتلال لاغلاق مع بري بيت
حانون وكرم ابو سالم لليوم الرابع على
التوالي وطالبت وزاره الصحه في غزه الجهات
ذات العلاقه بالضغط على الاحتلال لتسهيل
مغادره المرضى لانقاذ حياتهم قبل فوات
الاوان وحذر مكتب الاعلام الحكومي في غزه
من خطوره منع امدادات الوقود المشغل لمحطه
توليد الكهرباء في القطاع وقال ان العده
تنازليه للتوقف المحطه عن العمل قد بدا ما
ينذر بحدوث ازمه انسانيه وصحيه وبيئيه في
القطاع من جانبها قالت وكاله الغوث
الدوليه الاونرواي لتصعد الحالي يؤدي الى
تفاقم الوضع الانساني القاسي على لاجئي
فلسطين في قطاع غزه
ووصفات الخسائر في الارواح بين المدنيين
بمن فيهم النساء والاطفال بالماساه
الحقيقيه